twitter has temporarily restricted
president donald trump's campaign team
from tweeting
it was in response to a video of a fox
news interview with trump
where he made false claims about covid19
links to the tweet now arrive at this
page twitter says the post violated its
rules on covet 19 misinformation
and the owner must remove it before they
can tweet again the campaign appears to
have complied
hours earlier facebook also removed the
same video from president trump's main
page
it was the first time that facebook
removed one of trump's videos mike hanna
has more from washington d.c
well president trump stated in that
interview phone interview with
fox television that children are almost
immune from covert 19 or
virtually immune he said as well at a
different stage
now this is clearly and patently false
the centers for disease reserve research
the
cdc uh says that some quarter of a
million children
have contracted coronavirus and at least
six have actually
died of an acute inflammatory situation
uh stemming directly from cobard so this
is clearly
incorrect but what has got to be looked
at as well as the context that president
trump has used this phrase
virtually immune he has done it before
in public on a number of occasions
and the context is his absolute
insistence
that schools must open in the u.s in
their entirety
he does not want virtual education he
wants all the classes to open at the
beginning of the new school year
because he argues the economy cannot
revive unless children are back in
school freeing their parents to go to
work
so this is the context of these repeated
falsehoods
being made by president trump with
regard to
children and covert 19. rob pegararo is
a freelance tech writer he believes the
pandemic is playing a part in changing
facebook's approach
are we up to 157 000 americans dead from
this disease
that's part of it i think also facebook
historically
over the last few years we've seen they
do not want
to upset too many people around the
president to the extent where
a very pro-trump but inaccurate news
source like breitbart
does not get banned does not get blocked
gets a privileged spot
in the facebook news tab on their mobile
app uh
and they have gotten a lot of criticism
including from a lot of facebook
employees are not happy with the way
facebook has tried not to give offense
to the president and his supporters it
is a business
uh advertisers don't want to be in a
place that i would
i would assume that having a site
overrun with conspiracy theories would
not make it advertiser friendly
i don't think this is going to draw to
draw too many people away from facebook
the complaints people have about it i
was just writing about a survey the
other day of customer satisfaction where
the number one complaint was privacy
not is facebook mean to conservatives or
not
uh it is definitely true that some of
the same people in that house committee
hearing who accused zuckerberg
of and the other executives of being
biased against
republican voices will have another
talking point
even though actual evidence of that bias
i haven't seen it
trump seems to have done very well using
facebook as a megaphone
he certainly has an immensely large
audience